christine works at a movie store in her
hometown using the store's total
selection she documented the price of
each movie title and how many years it
has been since it was featured in movie
theaters she plotted the points below so
let's see what's going on below here so
let's see it looks like she there's two
curves that she tries to fit I'm
assuming we're going to read about in
that in a second but these blue points
are the data points so for example this
data point right over here shows a movie
that the title costs six dollars and it
has been released for almost two years a
little under two years this data point
right over here this is a movie that has
been released for looks like almost four
years it looks like maybe three and
three quarters years and it they're
selling that looks like for a dollar or
even a little bit less than a dollar so
those are her data points so once again
she documented the price of each movie
title as a function as a function of how
long it's been how many years it's been
since it was featured in movie theaters
she is looking for a function that
models her data since the trend of the
data is decreasing in convex and you see
it here when it's decreasing it's
definitely decreasing in convex it's
opening it's opening upwards if you
imagine a curve it looks like it's
opening upwards a little bit like that
so decreasing in convex she found a
decreasing convex exponential model and
a decreasing convex quadratic model so
which of the following better which of
the following functions better fits the
data so function a this is an
exponential this is the one in green
right over here and function B this one
right over here is a quadratic and you
can see this one in purple and so which
of one of those better fits the data and
so if we look at if we look at what's
going on here the green function the
exponential one most of the data points
for any given duration form you know how
long that titles been out it looks like
it's consistently under estimating that
it's always you know it's the models
guess for the or the model what the
model would say the price is is always
it
at least 4 except for only as
essentially except for only one data
point right over here for all of these
other data points it's under estimating
what the price would be the purple model
or the purple function right over here
it is it has a more of a balance between
overestimating right over here and so
it's overestimating by a little bit and
under estimating and it's under
estimates are closer and it's over
estimates are closer than this a green
model so I would say that function B is
definitely definitely a better a better
model use the function of best fit so
we're going to say function B to predict
the price of a movie that was featured
in theaters 5.5 years ago round your
answer to the nearest cent
so five point five years ago that's
going to be right over here we're going
to go to function B which is this purple
one so it's going to be you know it's
going to be under a dollar but we want
to get something to the nearest cent so
let's actually use the the actual
definition of the function so this is
price as a function of how long the
movie has been released where X is a how
long has it been released and Y is its
price so let's just let's just if X is
five point five let's figure out what Y
is going to be so it's going to be so Y
is going to be equal to zero point five
times x squared so X is five point five
five point five squared all right so
then we have minus 5 times X again so
minus five times five point five and
then we have plus 13 and what does that
get us
that gets us 60 two and a half cents if
we round our answer to the nearest cent
that's going to be 63 cents and we got
it right